Eric what is the Greek leadership's goal
this Monday the Greek leadership's go
tom is pretty much the impossible
because on the one hand it has to submit
a list of proposals to the Eurogroup
that satisfies people like Chancellor
Angela Merkel like the Finance Minister
Wolfgang schäuble well at the same time
maintaining solidarity within series of
the party that is in government here
that was swept into power on the back of
pre election promises that it was going
to end austerity what's obvious tom is
that austerity is here to stay the
question is how austerity is defined
Greece once a measure over that
definition on friday that it remains to
be seen how the finance minister VAR
Yanis varoufakis plans to put it into
practice all that we've heard from the
government thus far this morning were
promises to the Greek people we have not
seen anything of substance as to how
Greece is going to meet the targets set
for it by the Eurogroup tom Eric after
two or three weeks of briggeman search
ever since the new Greek government has
come into office what do you think that
mr. tsipras and mr. varoufakis have
learned about dealing with Europe
besides perhaps wearing a tie a lesson I
should point out that our Brennan
greeley has also picked up on well what
what's half they learned about dealing
with Europe what they've learned is that
they have almost no leverage let's put
it that way right the grease is bound to
the terms of the bailout what borough
farkas and the Prime Minister Alexis
tsipras wanted was some control over
their own destiny and they won some of
that but as I put it to our colleagues
in Europe this morning they still have
to hack off one of their limbs the
situation before was that the ECB the
IMF and the European Commission were
telling Greece which of their limbs had
to be hacked off now the Greek
government gets to decide is it going to
be my left arm is it going to be my
right leg but at the end of the day it
pretty much amounts to the same thing